[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
21 نسخه خلت من كاس العالم شاركت ثمانيه
منتخبات عربيه في الحدث الكروي الاعظم سجل
بعضها حضور باهدا وترك البعض اثرا لا ينسى
فما افضل المشاركات العربيه بالمونديال
[موسيقى]
عام 1970 وقع المغرب في مجموعه صعبه مع
انجلترا وكولندا والبرتغال تعادل سلبيا مع
انجلترا وبولندا وتغلب على البرتغال
بثلاثه اهداف بهدف ليتصدر مجموعاته
ويتاهلك اول فريق عربي الى ثمن نهائي
اصطدم المغرب في دوري 16 من ماكينات
الالمانيه وكان قاب قوسين او ادنى من
الذهاب الى وقت الاضافي لولا هدف من ضربه
حره في الدقيقه السابعه قليل من لوثر
ماتيوس انها مغامره الاسود
[موسيقى]
السعوديه مونديال
1994 بامريكا في المشاركه الاولى للصقور
الخضر وقع منتخبان عربيان لاول مره
واحده خسرت السعوديه مواجهتها الاولى
امامه هولندا قبل ان تصحح مسارها بفوزين
على المغرب ثم بلجيكا في مباراه احرز فيها
سعيد العويران احد اجمل اهداف المونديال
يوحنا الخضره ثانيا بعده هولندا رغم
تساويهما في الميقات لكن الطواحين تفوقت
في المواجهه المباشره في ثمن النهائي
ضاغطت السويد السعوديه بهدف مبكر في
الدقيقه السادسه ما اربه حسابات الفريق
لف مباراه بخساره الصقور الخضر بثلاثه
اهداف لهدف وتغادر السعوديه المونديال
الاول والابرز لها
[موسيقى]
الجزائر
مونديال 2014 بالبرازيل
وصل محاربوا الصحراء الى البرازيل كممثل
عربي وحيد قدمت الجزائر اداء الهجوميه
المميزه خسرت امام بلجيكا واكتسحت كوريا
الجنوبيه باربعه اهداف لهدفين قبل ان
تتعادل ايجابيا مع روسيا حاله الجزائر
ثانيه في مجموعتها لتتاهل للمره الاولى
للدور
اصطدمت الجزائر بالمانيا احد اقوى فرق
البطوله والتي فازت لاحقا باللقب لكن
الجزائر لم تكن مداينه تعادلت سلبيا مع
المانيا قبل ان تلجا الى الاشواط الاضافيه
ليخرج محارب الصحراء مرفوعين الراس في
واحده من اقوى المشاركات العربيه في تاريخ
المونديال
للمنتخبات العربيه بصمه حاضره في
المونديال لكنها لم تلبي طموحات عشاق
الكره العربيه الذين يحمون بمعانقه الذهب
في اليوم الذي يرفع فيه عربيه
اللقب الاغلى
[تصفيق]